salut la team candalot le nouvel iphone
est sorti c'est le septième du nom
étanche nouveau bouton home deux fois
plus de rapidité et de puissance et avec
le système d'exploitation le plus avancé
nu voilà pas déjà entendu ça tu essayé à
chaque fois la sortie du nouvel iphone
ça m'a donné envie de creuser pour voir
sur quel levier se basent apple pour
nous donner envie d'aller dans le futur
dans leur futur à eux tels qu'ils ont
pensé imaginé et comme vous pouvez le
constater mon présent c'est de vous
faire cette vidéo dans les loges puisque
je suis en spectacle dans quelques
heures la garenne-colombes tard on
regarde un petit peu de quelle manière
si prend apple on peut dire que oui chez
apple ils sont un petit peu mentalist
vous ne connaissez sûrement pas le
genius trény ça c'est un livre qu'on
donne à tous les nouveaux vendeurs de
chez apple qui vont travailler dans les
apple store les apple store physiques
parce qu'il ya pas de petits vendeurs
dans l'application goggles or dans ce
bouton on trouve tous les chapitres de
base sur le matériel etc a toutes les
caractéristiques techniques mais on
trouve aussi des chapitres très étonnant
comme le pouvoir de l'empathie qui
décrit précisément comment mettre en
confiance un acheteur et l'emmener
jusqu'à conclure une vente tout en lui
laissant le sentiment que c'est lui qui
a pris la décision d'acheter pas bête la
pomme donc en cherchant et ambroise
aignan j'en suis arrivé à la conclusion
que leurs vendeurs sont réellement des
comédiens ils leur demandent en tout cas
d'être comédien ils ont un rôle à jouer
ils ont même une liste de mots interdits
qui n'ont pas le droit de prononcer ou
encore des réactions très programmée en
fonction de certaines situations leur
règle d'or c'est aborder interrogé
présenter écouter est terminée en
anglais ça fait apple avec les initiales
et tout passe par l'identification par
exemple si un client trouve un mac trop
cher alors le vendeur va se positionner
comme étant annoncé un client ayant
accepté cela pourquoi pour que
l'acheteur s'identifie dans le vendeur
et du coup qui suivent le même
raisonnement et qu'ils achètent et qu'il
accepte qu'il auchel surtout exemple
très concret le client dit non mais
quand même le macbook cc c'est beaucoup
trop cher
le vendeur devra répondre quelque chose
disent ils oui je comprends
vous pensiez cela moi aussi je trouvais
que c'était trop cher pour un ordinateur
et puis j'ai trouvé ensuite le prix
complètement justifiée quand j'ai vu
toutes les capacités qu'ils avaient et
quel logiciel été installés en natif dès
le départ alors ça c'est vrai c'est en
boutique mais même en virtuel c'est à
dire sur internet et dans la
communication globale
il s'appuie sur plein de levier
psychologique qui sont hyper ciselé
lorsqu'en 2007 steve jobs présente le
premier iphone
ils rendent l'événement tellement gros
ça fait tellement de bruit dans le monde
entier que le cef qui était à las vegas
cette année-là et passer pour une fête
campagnarde personne n'en parle la
technique est très très simples données
très peu d'information est toujours au
compte gouttes
en faisant ça comme ça à chaque fois
qu'ils donnent une petite info aussi
petite soit elle tout le monde s'en
empare tous les spécialistes en parle
tous les blogs
un article dessus tout la rumeur enfle
ils jouent donc avec deux essentielles
créer le manque
et le désir et susciter la curiosité en
permanence et quand étudient leurs
techniques de communication c'est hyper
intéressant parce qu'ils se sont
attaqués à deux levier psychologique
très simple ils n'ont pas de
complexifier au contraire ils sont allés
à la base pour créer ce gros manques en
permanence après bien sûr ils ont
utilisé d'autres techniques ils me
disent en plus des techniques
commerciales pour pouvoir favoriser tout
ça dans un espèce de microcosmos par
exemple iran les clients captifs en
faisant tout fonctionné parle itunes et
en faisant en sorte que tous l'hardware
fonctionne bien l'un avec l'autre depuis
en créant l'apple store ils ont quand
même eu la bonne idée de faire
travailler tous les créatifs de la
planète pour eux gratos parce que ce
sont eux les programmateurs qui sortent
les applis que nous on aime et apple se
prend généreusement 30% de commission
sur toutes les applis qui sont vendus et
au final chez la pomme ils ont réussi à
créer un monde un univers un espèce de
bande on veut tous faire partie
j'ai remarqué quelque chose et c'est ça
aussi qui m'a motivé à faire cette vidéo
dans la vie quotidienne personne dit la
marque de ces objets j'allume mon ordi
je cherche où est mon téléphone je
recharge ma tablette mais quand tu as un
produit apple c'est différent tu allumes
ton bac tu cherches ou est-ce que tu as
mis ton iphone ou alors tu recherches
ton ipad et ça c'est une preuve qui ne
ment pas comme quoi ils ont réussi leurs
techniques d'identification
alors cette vidéo c'est pas une critique
du tout d'apple en soi parce que moi
j'adore cette marge est même beaucoup
trop de produits apple chez moi en
permanence j'aime bien renouveler ça ils
ont pour eux d'être visionnaire et ils
savent se rendre sexy
contrairement à d'autres marques qui
parfois ont les mêmes prétentions en
tout cas en logiciel ou un hardware vous
rend software mais on a moins envie
d'aller chez eux et la sortie de
l'iphone cet été une bonne occasion de
creuser un petit peu sur les techniques
qu'ils avaient employé chez apple depuis
le départ et vous en parler merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo jusqu'au
bout si vous êtes encore là au moment où
je parle vous pouvez mettre un pouce en
l'air si vous voulez me voir ailleurs
que dans une loge vous avez toutes les
dates de spectacles sur le site internet
il ya le lien dans le descriptif il ya
toujours tout ce que tu cherches dans le
descriptif à chaque fois et bien sûr
abonnez-vous avant de partir puisque le
mental fait que c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an
rendez vous demain à 11h ciao